wie arm wird Deutschland werden in
dieser Krise
es ist auf jeden Fall sicher dass
Verluste eintreten werden natürlich kann
niemand sagen was am Ende das Ergebnis
sein wird aber es gibt ja eine ganze
Reihe von Sachverständigen die meinen
20% Verlust an Wohlstand seien zu
befürchten und das wäre ja für viele
Menschen eine Einbuße die sie nicht
verkraften würden
[Musik]
Herr Hofreiter wir reden heute Abend
über Existenzängste ja Menschen die
wirklich Angst vorm Absturz haben haben
sie diese Menschen auch mit in diese
Situation gebracht
ich würde es mal so sagen der
Angriffskrieg Putins gegen die Ukraine
hat diese Menschen in die Situation
gebracht und man kann jetzt darüber
streiten ob die Regierung schon alles
getan hat was notwendig ist um die
Folgen abzumildern und da würde ich
sagen nein da gibt es noch einiges zu
tun es ist eine strompreisbremse
angekündigt die haben meisten Angst
haben ja die Leute versteigenden
Energiekosten die ja völlig durch die
Decke gehen die Zahlen die längst die
haben nicht nur Angst die Zahlen gelenkt
ja die Zahlen die zum Teil ich meine
sind ja längst und deswegen brauchen wir
in meinen Augen so schnell wie möglich
eine strompreisbremse und ich würde
sagen wir brauchen auch dringend eine
gaspreisbremse nicht das sind die beiden
Hauptursachen dafür wovor die Menschen
Angst haben es ist ja schon ein Schwung
getan worden es gab ja schon
Entlastungspaket eins zwei und drei es
ist für Rentner innen was getan worden
es ist für studieren dauert noch Monate
bis das auf dem Weg kommt die Gas
Abstandszahlung müssen aber jetzt eben
schon gezeigt auch schon auf dem Weg
aber wie gesagt wir müssen noch mehr tun
schauen wir gerade die Regierung dabei
inklus Deutschland beim Verfall beim
Zerfall zu dessen hartes Wort das habe
ich auch
formuliert vor kurzem in diese Richtung
ich denke dass die aktuellen
Energiepreis
Probleme
zusammenfallen mit einer schon länger
anhaltenden in der Tat
zerfallsentwicklung im Land in fast
allen Bereichen einfach dass wir sowohl
in den Eliten wie auch im Mittelstand
wie auch wir alle nicht mehr bereit sind
den Spitzenplatz einnehmen so wollen wir
lassen nach wir ruhen uns auf unserem
Büro statt in der Tabelle wir rutschen
ab sind schon abgerutscht in der Tabelle
und greifen jetzt natürlich auch noch in
die anderen Bereiche die noch gut
funktionieren hinein und das passiert
schon seit einigen Jahren und das ist
extrem bedenklich und dann kommen im
Grunde zwei Linien zusammen die in einer
fatalen Wirkung enden können ohne dass
ganz Kassandra rufen möchte
Herr mittelhoff ich habe gerade das
Beispiel von der Butter gezeigt bei Lidl
wo neuerdings in einigen Filialen
Sicherheitsetiketten draufkleben weil
man Diebstahl fürchtet bei ja so einem
Alltagsprodukt so war das bis vor kurzem
Butter das war mal deutsches
Wirtschaftswunder dass man endlich dick
Butter aufs Brot streichen konnte was
sagt das heute über unser Land aus das
Butter im Grunde zum Luxusgut wird ich
glaube Anknüpfen an das was der Gottlieb
gesagt das Problem aktuell ist nicht die
Butter sondern das Problem aktuell ist
dass wir
restrukturierungsbedarf haben in
Deutschland durch die Politik durch die
Wirtschaft in allen Bereichen und darauf
das kommt was her Hofreiter angesprochen
hat Ukraine ja und die damit verbundenen
Probleme und energiepreissteigung und
das dann das zu befürchten ist was er
Lafontaine eben dargelegt hat ein ganz
massiver
Einkommensverlust ganz massive Auflage
im Bereich der privaten Haushalte wie
groß ist jetzt der Anteil der Regierung
an dieser Krise daran dass so viele um
ihren Wohlstand fürchten müssen da
müssen wir die Regierung
auseinanderhalten ich glaube der erste
Teil die strukturellen Probleme die
gehen eindeutig auf das Konto derjenigen
die ungefähr 20 Jahre lang Verantwortung
für dieses Land hatten ganz eindeutig
Nachholbedarf in der Digitalisierung
Energieversorgung total Abhängigkeit von
Russland das ist ja nicht jetzt
entstanden das was wir jetzt aber
brauchen ist ein Masterplan also was wir
jetzt nicht brauchen ist nochmal Nils
Paket noch mal ist was natürlich müssen
wir den Bedürftigen helfen aber wir
müssen doch die directions vorgeben wir
müssen auch sagen in diese Richtung wird
dieses Land gesteuert hier nochmal an
die Rede von
Bundespräsident Herzog die rückrede wo
er gesagt hat alle sind angesprochen
alle müssen Beitrag leisten
und das ist das was wir jetzt uns klar
sein der Druck ist nämlich nach wie vor
nicht gekommen
die Politik die Politik alleine kann das
nicht richten wir sind in einer
Situation in dem jeden klar sein muss
und das auch gesagt werden muss dass
jeder ein Beitrag leisten muss und
gleichzeitig müssen nie abgesichert
werden die nicht in der Lage sind das zu
überstehen jetzt hat er mittelhoffteller
Fontaine den Beitrag auch der alten
Region der Regierung Merkel genannt wie
hoch ist der Beitrag an dieser Krise von
dem man bzw dessen Regierung hier neben
mir sitzt von Anton Hofreiter
also wir müssen das Hauptproblem sehen
das Hauptproblem ist die Entwicklung der
Energiepreise und ich sehe nicht dass
die Vorgängerregierung von der jetzt die
Rede war die Entwicklung der
Energiepreise in großem Umfang
beeinflusst hat
beeinflusst wurde diese Entwicklung
durch die Entscheidung viele
sanktionspakete zu machen und die
Reaktion der Russen auf diese
sanktionspakete mit Einschränkungen der
Energielieferungen zu antworten das
heißt also die Kernfrage ist nicht
unbedingt dies oder jenes was jetzt
entschieden wird die Kernfrage ist wie
kriegen wir den Energiepreise runter und
da muss die Bundesregierung und das ist
ihr Anteil endlich begreifen dass ihre
Entscheidung dieser ganze
sanktionspakete mitzutragen uns gibt war
ja die Rede davon wir wollen jetzt
unabhängig vom Gas sein sofort und wir
wollen was weiß ich vom Öl das wollen
wir auch abschaffen dass diese
Entscheidung einfach völlig über alt
waren wenn man sie also schon lösen will
von einem Lieferanten da muss man das
behutsam machen dass man nicht selber
eben sich ein Bein stellt und jetzt
sieht man das eben der große
Standortvorteil der deutschen Industrie
das waren den niedrigen Energiepreise
durch Fehlentscheidung der Regierung
eben dann die russische Reaktion
hervorgerufen haben im letztendlich
gekommen sind und es ist ja nicht nur
die Industrie die Leute sind es ist auch
die Bevölkerung die leidet und die
Regierung ist jetzt endlich begreifen
dass sie auf dem falschen Weg ist und
muss umkehren wir werden den Wohlstand
ohne billige Energie nicht halten können
und billige Energie gibt es nicht aus
Katar nicht aus den USA nicht sonst
woher sie gibt es nur aus Russland wer
das nicht begreift verschließt die Augen
vor der Wertigkeit also Freitag von
Themen macht ganz klar sie
beziehungsweise die aktuelle ampelregion
dafür verantwortlich und sagt sie haben
einen einfachen Ausweg sie brauchen halt
die russische Energie die
Sanktionspolitik ist schuld da der
deswegen verlieren wir den Wohlstand
hier in Deutschland es ist die
klassische Reaktion der putinfreunde der
Leute die die fünfte Kolonne Putins hier
bei uns darstellen und die die
Demokratie und die Diktatur ausliefern
aber wollen das ist typisch es ist
nichts anderes zu erwarten dabei
funktionieren die Sanktionen extrem gut
Russlands
Zuschüsse sind im August kollabiert die
Sanktionen
führen bereits dazu dass die russische
Rüstungsindustrie drüber
lachen aber die Zahlen sind trotzdem
eindeutig und das weißt du wirklich
industrieorientieren und dann den
Preisen und nicht von putinverstehen und
ähnlichem reden sie müssen eine Antwort
geben die halbwegs ernst zu leben ist
wie kriegen wir die Preise runter dass
ein marktvorgang wenn man also die
russischen Gasmengen und Ölmengen von
europäischen Markt wegnimmt da muss
Europa zu überteuerten Preisen überall
in der Welt einkaufen und sie sind damit
mitverantwortlich für diesen Anstieg der
Preise und wenn sie das nicht verstehen
dann sind sie mitverantwortlich für die
Verarmung der Bevölkerung das sind
Tatsachen da kann man nicht mehr herum
reden und nicht sagen Putin verstehe
oder ähnlichen und das ist ein brutaler
Vorwurf an sie Hero Freitag bzw an ihren
Wirtschaftsminister an ihren
Bundeskanzler mein Gott das ist halt die
Propaganda Putins die immer wieder hier
in Deutschland wiederholt wird
verantwortlich ist natürlich Putin mit
seinem Angriff
auf die Ukraine ohne jeden Grund also
ohne also des Weiteren und jetzt rede
ich erstmal Herr Lafontaine und des
Weiteren sozusagen haben wir deshalb
Sanktionen erlassen um diesen Krieg zu
beenden und die Sanktionen wirken im
August sozusagen hat Russland massive
Staatsdefizit und sie bewirken auch dass
die russische Rüstungsindustrie bereits
in großen Schwierigkeiten ist sie finden
russischen Panzern immer öfters
Waschmaschinen und spülmaschinenchips
und man darf nicht vergessen die
russische Armee foltert mordet
vergewaltigt und da einfach zu sagen das
ist uns egal wir machen einfach so
weiter und Kaufen bei dieser Diktatur
billig Energie das ist einfach mehr als
unanständig und wird uns langfristig
wenn wir es so machen würden ökonomisch
noch viel mehr kosten weil wir nämlich
viel in die anderen europäischen Länder
exportieren viele in die USA exportieren
und als Verbündeter eines
allerersteigenden diktatorischen
Russlands wird man den Wohlstand ganz
sicher wieder verteilen sie sagen Herrn
hofreit sind die Menschen hier ist die
neue Armut hier in Deutschland egal er
ruft weiter Pfeffer zurück und sagt
ihnen sind die Massengräber egal ihnen
sind die Kriegsverbrechen egal
ja das ist nun leider eben wie soll ich
mal sagen sachlich überhaupt nicht
haltbar nach der Aussage von Herrn
Hofreiter ist zum Beispiel Frankreich
ein unmögliches Land weil das hat ja
seine gaseinfuhren aus Russland enorm
gesteigert ich weiß noch ein hochreitert
als weiß denn ist also dann alles egal
oder ich nehme Japan die machen einen
solche dummheit muss ich sagen nicht wie
die deutsche Regierung die sagen also
die Industriestadt wir verzichten nicht
auf Russisch Gas wir beuten sogar mit
den Russen zusammen die Gasvorräte auf
Sachalin aus also so dumm wie die
deutsche Regierung stellt sich keine
Regierung in der Welt an das muss man in
dieser Härte sagen ganz kurz ist es auch
propagant
und Japan halten sich an die Sanktionen
es gab nämlich nie Sanktionen gegen
russisches Gas das ist einfach die
Entscheidung von Putin und wenn Putin
morgen entscheidet Frankreich nichts
mehr zu liefern dann kriegt Frankreich
nichts mehr
weiter ganz kurz natürlich sind uns die
armen Leute nicht egal gibt es
entlastungspakete und deswegen habe ich
vorher gesagt muss auch noch mehr
passieren und zwar in meinen Augen ein
strompreisdeckel und ein gaspreisdeckel
ist angekommen jetzt zeigt dieser Streit
ja genau dass die Lämmer in dem wir
gerade stecken wir haben diese Woche
berichtet über den Rentner Dietmar aus
Zwickau der seine erste
gasabschlagszahlung bekommen hat und der
zeigt genau das was er Lafontaine gerade
gesagt hat der hat sein Leben lang
gearbeitet der hat eine ordentliche
Rente und jetzt bekommt er auf einen
Schlag einen monatsabschlagszahlung von
2.200 Euro und sogar noch ein bisschen
mehr auf dem Tisch der wird sich sehr
schwer tun Herrn Hofreiter noch
zuzuhören und zu sagen ja das ist weiter
richtig mit den Sanktionen das ist
weiter Richtung richtig mit den
Waffenlieferung ich verliere hier gerade
ein Wohlstand wie lösen wir das Dilemma
nicht nur an Wohlstand wahrscheinlich
geht es bei ihm gar nicht mehr und
Wohlstand sondern es geht um die
Existenz ein
Existenzminimum im wahrsten Sinn des
Wortes und der Rentner wird weitersagen
also einen Streit wie wir ihn eben hier
erlebt haben der hilft mir nicht weiter
das wieder der klassische politische
Intro fight sondern ich möchte wissen
wie ich durch den Winter komme mit
welchen Mitteln mit welchen Maßnahmen
mich diese Bundesregierung die aus drei
Parteien besteht unterstützen wird so
dass ich nicht im kalten Wohnzimmer
sitze und dass ich meine und mein Brot
mit der Butter bestreichen kann von der
sie eben gesprochen haben in der Tat und
dann steht der Rentner drittens fest
dass er im Augenblick wenn Herr
Hofreiter sagt da ist der gaspreisdeckel
in Aussicht da ist der Stromkreis Deckel
in Aussicht dann wird er sagen ja in
Aussicht aber es ist noch nichts
vollzogen es ist noch nichts gemacht und
ich habe gestern noch mit einer Reihe
von Unternehmen des Mittelstandes des
kleinen Mittelstandes gesprochen und die
sagen ja Ankündigung jeden Tag eine neue
Umsetzung Null das heißt also dieser
Rentner steht nach diesem Zeit
Lafontaine Hofreiter und nach dieser
bisherigen
energiedeckelungsabsicht steht vor 0
Position also das heißt der wird sich
überhaupt hier nicht aufgehoben fühlen
und das ist das Problem
das mache ich diese Regierung zu der
auch die Grünen natürlich gehören wie
Sie wissen mache ich das zum Vorwurf das
ist ein komplexes riesiges Thema dass
wir im Augenblick besprechen da möchte
ich mit keinem verantwortlichen
Politiker tauschen wir tun uns leicht
hier sozusagen die die gute Option hier
zu fordern aber ich erwarte Handwerk und
ich erwarte schnelle Umsetzung und ich
erwarte auch einen Tisch an dem ich mich
mit den Leuten setze die davon betroffen
sind mit den Unternehmen all das ist nur
bisher mit Verzögerung passiert und wenn
sie mit haarig reden dann gibt er ihnen
inzwischen auch sie sind sie sind
Unternehmer sie sind Manager gewesen
ganz lange Zeit der mittelhoff stimmt
das was Herr Gottlieb gerade sagt die
fühlen sich gar nicht mitgenommen die
die Klagen über Inkompetenz über
Fachkräftemangel innerhalb der
Bundesregierung ich Stimme hören
Gottlieb absolut zu und wenn ich noch
mal einen Schritt zurückgehen darf ich
möchte Hannah von denen an einem Punkt
widersprechen die Verantwortung für die
Abhängigkeit Energieabhängigkeit von
Russland ja die ist so entschieden so
entwickelt worden und es war doch jedem
deutlich dass Deutschland ein Land ohne
Ressourcen ohne Energieressourcen ist
und da ist dran es bringt mir heute uns
allen natürlich gar nichts mehr zu sagen
damals nein es ist schon wichtig für die
Entscheidung kurzfristig mittelfristig
und langfristig wie richte ich dieses
Land neu aus kurzfristig kommen wir doch
relativ schnell zu der Frage ja
Sanktionen ja Position beziehen im
Rahmen der Ukraine Krieges aber auf der
anderen Seite sind wir bereit doch mit
Russland zu verhandeln um Gas und
Energieversorgung sicherzustellen ja
oder nein und da möchte ich mal einen
deutschen Minister sehen deren Amtseid
abgelegt hat dass er also zum Wohle der
Bevölkerung und und abhält das ist eine
ganz schwierige Entscheidungssituation
so was wir brauchen ist genau das was
der Gottlieb gesagt das schwierigen
entscheidungsposition in Situation unser
commitment zu westlicher Welt und
Verteidigung der Demokratie ja
moralische Werte vor allen Dingen und
auf der anderen Seite Versorgung der
Bürger der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
mit Energie die bezahlbar an wir schauen
uns noch mal den Amtseid des
Bundeskanzlers an wie das im Bundestag
außer vor einem Dreivierteljahr etwa das
erste Eid den der Kanzler zu sprechen
hat und viele Deutsche sagen jetzt
Mensch
der hält sich jetzt nicht dran mit
seiner Energiepolitik aktuell wir
schauen uns mal an seinen Amtszeit
ich schwöre dass ich meine Kraft dem
Wohle des deutschen Volkes widmen
seinen Nutzen mehreren Schaden von ihm
wenden ich schwöre einmal tut er das
Schaden von ihm zu wenden wenn Leute wie
dieser Rentner Dietmar den wir besucht
haben in Zwickau eine unfassbare
Energierechnung hat eine Rechnung die
höher ist als sie möglicherweise sein
müsste er tut es nicht wenn ihr die
wichtigen Entscheidungen ungefähren
beläst also wenn im Ungefähren bleibt ob
panzler geliefert werden oder nicht und
dem ungefähren bleibt wie denn
bezahlbare Energie jetzt in den
Wintermonaten zur Verfügung gestellt
werden soll und wenn dann der Bürger
fast jeden Tag neue tatar-nachrichten
bekommt ja dann muss man sich nicht
wundern dass die ich würde mal sagen das
Vertrauen in die politischen Führung ein
bisschen angekratzt ist also Herr
mittelhofft er sagt hier ist sogar der
Amtseid sozusagen den man gesch hat der
wird nicht der wird nicht mit Leben
gefüllt aktuell es wird alles im
Ungefähren gelassen auch die Strompreise
im Ungefähren die Gaspreise im ungefähr
also ich meine ich habe Scholz auch
schon öfters kritisiert aber irgendwann
wird es halt doch albern oder billig man
sollte einmal die Kirche im Dorf lassen
gleich da am Zeit verletzt dann was weiß
ich man muss sofort alles machen ja ich
meine die Regierung ja die Regierung
sozusagen hat innerhalb kürzester Zeit
sind wir dabei am Gast Terminals zu
bauen wir lassen die Atomkraftwerke
länger laufen wir sind bereit ja nein
also
ist das neu das wäre eine echte Meldung
sie lassen die Atomkraftwerke länger
laufen wird mit der Einschränkung ja
klar sie dürfen nicht mehr Strom
produzieren als sie benötigen sonst
kriegen sie das Netz auch zum krachen
das hat man schon mal dann wir haben
wahrscheinlich Ende des Jahres das erste
Gast Terminal das ist innerhalb weniger
eines Jahres dann bereits drei
entlastungspakete und ich habe schon
gesagt ja ich bin der Meinung und das
kritisiere ich auch dass die Regierung
sich noch nicht entschieden hat an
strompreisdeckel und dann gaspreisdeckel
für den Durchschnittsverbrauch zu
erlassen aber sozusagen sich diese
Vielzahl von Krisen anzuschauen und wir
haben ja noch weitere Krisen die
Klimakrise ist dieses Jahr auch wieder
völlig eskaliert da rein hatte fast kein
Wasser mehr deswegen konnten die Schiffe
nicht drauf vernünftig fahren und so
weiter diese Vielzahl von Krisen und
dann sollen wir alles was in 16 Jahren
verzollt worden ist aber wenn nein nein
das hat keiner von ihnen gefordert man
hat nur gefordert einfach irgendwann
weil wir alle die Abschlagszahlung halt
sofort zahlen müssen und lassen das
Paket das was sie immer feiern das ist
beschlossen aber da ist noch das Geld
das ist ganz ganz weit in der Ferne aber
das war war
schneller gehen aber ich frage uns heute
die Kirche was auch irgendwo im Dorf
doch was nee lassen
so ähnlich formuliert die im Moment
sagen Mensch die haben die Interessen
der Menschen in der Ukraine im Blick
aber unsere unsere Interessen unser
Portemonnaie das haben die im Moment
viel zu wenig im Blick
das stimmt auf den ersten Blick ist das
eine eine richtige feststellen auf den
zweiten Blick würde ich jetzt hier ein
bisschen in Richtung Hofreiter gehen und
sagen also machen wir es mal jetzt am
Bundeskanzler fest sozusagen diesen
Schaden vom Rentner abzuhalten hat
natürlich eine zweifache Dimension es
ist einmal die sozusagen ökonomische
Existenzminimum Ebene und das andere ist
sozusagen die globale auch der Rentner
Huber wie immer er heißt mag und will im
Frieden leben und erwartet von der
Regierung im Lande natürlich dass sie
die Voraussetzungen für eine solche so
friedliche
existenziell und beides musst du auf
Wochen erklären auf eine Ebene bringen
und da sage ich müssen sie erklären da
haben wir ein gewaltiges
erklärungsdefizit in der Regierung und
vor allem ein gewaltiges
erklärungsdefizit beim Bundeskanzler